do you think there is a crisis in the
world and could be advertised
earth solve it first of all if there is
a crisis in the world the job is to
define it the second thing I think which
is where I am optimistic where the
reason I'm optimistic for the world in a
sense is that really in a way progress
happens not so much by the generation of
new ideas but by the abandonment of old
assumptions and a few of the things
we're beginning to understand now are
for example complexity in general now if
you look at a complex system which is
closest of say a meteorological system
than it is to a simple mechanical system
like a clockwork mechanism such as a
watch it's more complicated to model and
vertically it's far more difficult to
change you can't use simple Newtonian
physics in meteorology nor can you use
it in economies or in psychology for
example it simply isn't that simple
that's the bad news that actually
working out how to fixed it is harder
the one piece of good news is that
sometimes fairly large problems can be
solved by fairly small interventions
butterfly theory if you like and that's
the one area where I'm I'm optimistic if
we start to understand the complex
systems and difficult and different from
simple systems and that treating
economies as if they're like some sort
of mechanism involving a couple of cogs
and a lever is fundamentally fallacious
once we start to realize that then first
of all we'll stop this business of
always trying to have big effect by
creating a wholesale change there may be
very very small interventions very small
ideas that to have absolutely massive
effects here in Holland is very
interesting case which I was regard as
just a small example of that where the
typical mechanistic view of the world
says if you want people to slow down
when they're driving down a particular
stretch of road you place a speed camera
there and that's the kind of logical
Newtonian incentives disincentives
economic model for how you change
behavior to some extent it doesn't work
all that well for reasons I won't go
into
now what they found somewhere in Holland
was with a apparently illogical
intervention simply removing the lines
painted on the road causes people to
slow down instinctively without even
being aware that they're doing it so
Buckminster Fuller talked about this
idea of trim tab which is the point on a
ship or a plane where the smallest
movement creates the biggest change and
actually on his gravestone it says call
me trim tab that showed an early
understanding I think of complexity this
kind of understanding that two things
one it's not easy it's not simple and
predictable and mechanistic therefore we
should stop trying to change the world
through grant necessarily through grand
interventions that caused considerable
disruption and we should spend time
looking for and incidentally failing in
the search for smaller interventions
which may achieve greater things at with
far fewer unintended consequences so
that that's where i'm optimistic first
of all we need to accept that actually
this is an imperfect science and
actually experimentation and failure and
modification and so for there as much
part of the process as having a grand
vision the second thing is to understand
that actually it isn't necessary to seek
to change the world in order to change
it I'm sure there are people now dead
some people now alive who have
significantly changed the world and yet
we don't even know their names a lot
assumption that in order to change the
world you have to stage a revolution or
achieve massive political power or some
you know enormous sort of upheaval in
the way things are ordered and organized
maybe one of the great misconceptions
we're starting to abandon the trim tab
interventions as Bucky would have called
them are actually much much more
interesting in order to make this
succeed first of all politics has got to
understand that first of all its own
sense of self aggrandizement often it
requires it to do massive high-profile
high budget interventions these may not
actually be the best use of politicians
time and the second thing politician has
got to
is learn to get less embarrassed about
failure and say we tried this small
thing it didn't succeed very well the
ill effects were relatively trivial
relax about it if you look at the
business world it really does work
through at its best Silicon Valley as
one example through stochastic tinkering
and experimentation that's not my phrase
that's the same Talib's I think
stochastic tinkering is how it works and
one of the rate things about the
business world is that when a new idea
comes along entrepreneurs will try and
implement that idea and indeed knock it
that idea in six very different ways and
maybe only one of them succeeds that to
some extent is why capitalism works
because actually the rewards for trying
something different in capitalism are
quite high if everybody else is wrong
and you're right the rewards if you put
money in the game for being proven right
a really pretty high you might argue
that cultures like politics cultures
like the public sector and academia
there's much more reputation illrick
involved and actually the price of
dissent is very high and the potential
reward is very very small so the great
thing about the great thing about
business is if you actually just that
there is this extraordinary reward for
actually looking at the world
differently you may fail quite a bit but
when you succeed it really does pay off
and relatively rapidly I think you know
there is quite a lot that academia and
politics can learn from how free markets
actually work I don't mean the deluded
sort of neoclassical view of that the of
the perfect efficient market I mean the
kind of Shumpert Irion view of you know
creative destruction and entrepreneurial
activity the fact that actually you know
this isn't actually and you know an
unstable thing in common constant desig
disequilibrium which is forever just
searching for relative advantage over a
competing company or a competing idea
and that and to translate that not
that's boring bit about the perfectly
efficient market what they've done in
trying to introduce markets into say the
public sector is actually to introduce
some of the less attractive unless you
aspects of the public sector into these
businesses but if you could actually
understand that there's a kind of
dynamic competitive market for ideas
approaches and indeed for marketing
approaches and here's my most radical
suggestion which will seem to you very
web if you believe that values
subjective there's no reason why the
next big revolution couldn't be
psychological not technological if we
simply better understood what people
valued how they behaved and what made
people happy that could actually raise
the quality of human life just as
significantly I would argue far more
significantly than some new widget or
battery-powered device they may be
slightly interconnected that's the first
point and so it far more intelligent
effort needs to go into understanding
what you might call intangible value not
just how to make material stuff after
all we materially quite well off in the
developed world already you know our
appetite for stuff isn't infinite part
for anything else you run out of storage
space so understanding the value of
intangibles and services and so forth I
think you know I think can lead some
really important innovation I think
that's a dangerous thing about
innovation that it tends to be conflated
with a particular kind of technological
progress where is actually innovation
takes place in all manner of different
places in distribution but also in
marketing if you can work out new ways
of understanding consumer needs in a way
that's much closer to the grain of human
nature then business efficiency can
significantly improve without
necessarily needing to change all that
much what it actually makes or supplies
does that sound too weird I'm not a lot
of people a lot of people look at this
again it's dangerously case to either
propaganda or to kind of brave new world
where we're drugged into being content
with our own circumstances I'm just
saying there's no awful lot of wasted
effort the other the final question is
how many technological problems are
really marketing problems or
psychological problems in disguise so
I'm quite a keen fan of nicotine not a
fashionable point of view I accept the
parable thing with nicotine was the
delivery device and the electronic
cigarette seems to me a very important
invention it's quite a lot of the
pleasure of smoking but with perhaps you
know small
centage of the risk the problem isn't
the technology that's already there in
existing the problem is a whole load of
social pressures and frames around the
fact that it's just embarrassing to
smoke electronic cigarettes in public
the driverless car Google's more or less
perfected that the problem when the
driverless clys no longer technological
in principle it's legislative how do we
legislate for this for blame in terms of
software that goes slightly wrong and
causes the you know a minor accident
equal it's also psychological how do you
design cars in such a way that gradually
gets people to accept that you can be
walking down a pavement and a device
with no human in it passes you at 30
miles an hour and that's the real
challenge the driverless car isn't the
technology anymore